I would say the finale of Breaking Bad
is maybe the most satisfying finale of
all time mmm what was the deciding
factor in doing this movie Vince you
know Vince Gilligan are our fearless
leader look he doesn't have to do this
movie he's dealing with a legacy that is
breaking bad I mean he cares more about
Breaking Bad than any one on the planet
and any huge massive crazy psychotic fan
he doesn't want to mess it up of course
not and so he calls me one day I was in
New York and he asks me what my thoughts
were on about possibly playing this guy
again I go what do you mean he was I
have an film idea Ivan wrote it yet but
I want her to gauge your interest and
he's like look I don't want to put the
cart before the horse here but I only
want to do this movie if it's perfect
and so I'll call you you know I'll let
you know when it's done yeah cut to
seven months later he he calls me and
says it's done and I I think it's next
to perfect so here we are I don't know
how you guys pulled off the guests
surprise gemios in there what went into
keeping Bryan Cranston's appearance a
secret uh spoiler alert spoilers ah that
was you know they shuttled him in and
out on a private plane and Netflix has a
lot of money Thank You Netflix but yeah
that was that was actually so much fun
to play because I haven't played that
version of Jesse in so long that was
kind of the lighter times before many
deaths you know has happened in his life
before he was a murderer
and so it was nice to kind of zip on
that guy again and the like free-loving
just he's like in love with Jane she's
still alive overdose yet yeah
which cameo was the hardest to keep
secret I mean honest for me was also
easy okay yeah I mean I don't like to
spoil anything yeah so it was a
no-brainer for me to just just don't
talk about it yeah you know I mean I
care so much about this film and these
characters that you know why ruin
something good um and so it was
incredibly easy for me to keep it a
secret
even when I was shooting in New Mexico
anyone that would come up to me asking
me why I was there they automatically
assumed oh maybe it had something better
call Saul related but I would just say I
was there for you know an indie project
and that was it I do have a very serious
question yes why did we not see sky Walt
Jr the baby no you know I don't know
they went through hell you know I think
that's a much bigger story to tell and
so I think I think Vince just wanted to
focus on Jesse and sort of his escape
and
that's it is that for the next movie I
don't even talked about oh I don't know
you know I thought I'd say goodbye to
this guy a long time ago I'm just happy
to kind of revisit him for this the
letter to Brock what did that signify to
you that that was the only person he
really wanted to say yeah I do
um you know what actually the first
thing that Vince Gilligan ever wrote for
this film was that letter right and the
initial draft that I read the letter was
in there you saw what was inside the
letter that was the first thing he wrote
and then he brought the rest of the
script and what was inside that letter
was just so beautiful and heartbreaking
and honest I'm just so so I hope one day
that people are able to to see what was
inside that letter you ready
yeah how do you feel overall about the
journey that Jesse went on this in this
movie and if there was more story to
tell what that entail I just feel so
blessed to play this guy to be in the
skin and tell this story and have
someone like vent its kind of trusting
me to portray this character I think
what they did with the show was so
perfect and I thought I think we talked
about earlier I thought the ending was
really perfect but I think this next
chapter is a very delicate approach on
the continuation of this story and any
fan of the show is going to be a huge
fan of this film and I'm just incredibly
proud of it
I saw in the credits you of course thank
your wife Lauren yes my baby and your
baby so I was gonna ask you at what age
will you let your child watch Breaking
Bad oh man I mean what I honestly
whenever she shows interest I mean you
know I don't think it's something that I
should start playing her on her sixth
birthday or anything but yeah maybe I
mean she's 12 13 yeah
does the family feel complete no god no
you want more kids yeah yeah how many is
there a number you talked to my wife
about that I mean I'm down to just keep
on going
yeah I know I mean I my life began once
I had had a baby girl my god and
watching my my wife her take on a role
of a mother it's just such a this is
such a joy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]